[Music]
Reflections on language
preface
part one of this book is an elaboration
of the wooden lectures
delivered in January 1975. at McMaster
University
part two is a revised version of my
contribution to a volume of essays in
honor of yehoshua bar Hillel edited by
kosher
submitted for publication in June 1974.
the latter essay considers some critical
discussion of the general point of view
developed here
as it had been presented in earlier work
to preserve the internal coherence of
the discussion in part two
I have retained some material that
recapitulates themes that are developed
in a somewhat different form in the
wooden lectures
I have presented much of this material
in lectures at MIT and elsewhere
and am indebted to many students
colleagues and friends for valuable
comments and criticism
the work reviewed in Chapter 3 of part 1
in particular
incorporate suggestions and research to
which many people have contributed
as the citations only partially serve to
indicate among others Harry Bracken
Donald hockney Ray jakandoff Justin
Lieber Julius moravcik and Henry
Rosemont have made helpful comments on
an earlier version of this manuscript
I have also profited greatly from Lively
and extensive discussions with members
of The Faculty of McMaster University
Noam Chomsky
Cambridge Massachusetts
April 1975.
part 1.
the wait in lectures
chapter 1.
uncognitive capacity
these Reflections on the study of
language will be non-technical for the
most part
and will have a somewhat speculative and
personal character
I'm not going to try to summarize the
current state of knowledge in the areas
of language study that I know something
about
or to discuss ongoing research in any
depth
I want to consider rather the point and
purpose of the Enterprise
to ask and I hope explain
why results obtained in technical
Linguistics might interest someone who
is not initially Enchanted by the
relation between question formation and
anaphora the principles of rule ordering
in phonology
the relation of intonation to the scope
of negation and the like
I will sketch what seems to me an
appropriate framework within which the
study of language may prove to have more
General intellectual interest
and will consider the possibilities for
constructing a kind of theory of human
nature on a model of this sort
why study language
there are many possible answers and by
focusing on some I do not of course mean
to disparage others or question their
legitimacy
one may for example Simply Be fascinated
by the elements of language in
themselves and want to discover their
order and Arrangement their origin in
history or in the individual
or the ways in which they are used in
thought in science or in art
or in normal social interchange
one reason for studying language
and for me personally the most
compelling reason
is that it is tempting to regard
language in the traditional phrase
as a mirror of mind
I do not mean by this simply that the
concepts expressed and distinctions
developed in normal language use give us
insights into the patterns of thought
and the world of Common Sense
constructed by the human mind
more intriguing to me at least
is the possibility that by studying
language we may discover abstract
principles that govern its structure and
use
principles that are Universal by
biological necessity and Not Mere
historical accident
that derive from mental characteristics
of the species
human language is a system of remarkable
complexity
to come to know a human language would
be an extraordinary intellectual
achievement for a creature not
specifically designed to accomplish this
task
a normal child acquires this knowledge
on relatively slight exposure and
without specific training
he can then quite effortlessly make use
of an intricate structure of specific
rules and guiding principles to convey
his thoughts and feelings to others
arousing in them novel ideas and subtle
perceptions and judgments
for the conscious mind not specially
designed for the purpose it remains a
distant goal to reconstruct and
comprehend what the child has done
intuitively and with minimal effort
thus language is a mirror of mind in a
deep and significant sense
it is a product of human intelligence
created and new in each individual by
operations that lie far beyond the reach
of will or consciousness
by studying the properties of natural
languages
their structure organization and use
we may hope to gain some understanding
of the specific characteristics of human
intelligence
we may hope to learn something about
human nature something significant if it
is true that human cognitive capacity is
the truly distinctive and most
remarkable characteristic of the species
furthermore it is not unreasonable to
suppose that the study of this
particular human achievement
the ability to speak and understand a
human language
may serve as a suggestive model
for inquiry into other domains of human
competence and action that are not quite
so amenable to direct investigation
the questions that I want to consider
are classical ones
in major respects we have not progressed
Beyond classical Antiquity in
formulating clear problems in this
domain
or in answering questions that
immediately arise
from Plato to the present time
serious philosophers have been baffled
and intrigued by the question that
Bertrand Russell in one of his later
works formulated in this way
how comes it that human beings whose
contacts with the world are brief and
personal and limited are nevertheless
able to know as much as they do know
how can we gain such Rich systems of
knowledge
given our fragmentary and impoverished
experience
a dogmatic skeptic might respond that we
do not have such knowledge
his qualms are irrelevant to the present
point
the same question arises as a question
of science if we ask how comes it that
human beings with such limited and
personal experience achieve such
convergence enrich and highly structured
systems of belief
systems which then guide their actions
and interchange and their interpretation
of experience
in the classical tradition several
answers were suggested
one might argue along Aristotelian lines
that the world is structured in a
certain way and that the human mind is
able to perceive this structure
ascending from particulars to species to
genus to further generalization and thus
attaining knowledge of universals from
perception of particulars
a basis of pre-existent knowledge is a
prerequisite to learning
we must possess an innate capacity to
attain developed states of knowledge but
these are neither innate in a
determinate form nor developed from
other higher states of knowledge but
from sense perception
given Rich metaphysical assumptions it
is possible to imagine that a mind so
constituted as to be capable of this
process of induction might attain a rich
system of knowledge
a more fruitful approach shifts the main
burden of explanation from the structure
of the world to the structure of the
Mind
what we can know is determined by the
modes of conception in the understanding
what we do know then or what we come to
believe
depends on the specific experiences that
evoke in us some part of the cognitive
system that is latent in the mind
in the modern period primarily under the
influence of Cartesian thought
the question of what we can know became
again a central topic of inquiry
two leibniz and cudworth
Plato's doctrine that we do not attain
new knowledge but recover what was
already known seemed plausible when this
Doctrine was purged of the error of
pre-existence
cudworth argued at length that the mind
has an innate cognositive power that
provides the principles and conceptions
that constitute our knowledge
when provoked by sense to do so
but sensible things themselves as for
example light and colors are not known
and understood either by the passion or
the fancy of sense
nor by anything merely foreign and
adventitious
but by intelligible ideas exerted from
the Mind itself that is by something
native and domestic to it
thus knowledge consisteth in The
Awakening and exciting of the inward
active powers of the Mind
which exercises its own inward activity
upon the objects presented by sense
thus coming to know or understand
actively to comprehend a thing by some
abstract free and Universal ratios
reasonings
the eye perceives but the mind can
compare analyze see cause and effect
relations symmetries and so on
giving a comprehensive idea of the whole
with its parts relations and proportions
the book of nature then is legible only
to an intellectual eye He suggests just
as a man who reads a book in a language
that he knows can learn something from
the inky Scrolls the primary objects of
Science and intellection namely the
intelligible Essences of things
exist nowhere but in the mind itself
being its own ideas
and by and through these inward ideas of
the Mind itself which are its primary
objects does it know and understand all
external individual things
which are the secondary objects of
knowledge only
among the innate ideas or common Notions
discussed in the rich and varied work of
17th century rationalists are for
example geometrical concepts and the
like but also relational ideas or
categories which enter into every
presentation of objects and make
possible the unity and
interconnectedness of rational
experience
including such relative Notions as cause
effect whole and part like an unlike
proportion and analogy equality and
inequality Symmetry and asymmetry all
relative ideas
that are no material impresses from
without upon the soul but her own active
conception proceeding from herself
whilst she takes notice of external
objects
tracing the development of such ideas we
arrive at kant's rather similar concept
of the Conformity of objects to our mode
of cognition
the Mind provides the means for an
analysis of data as experience
and provides as well a general
schematism that delimits the cognitive
structures developed on the basis of
experience
returning to Russell's query we can know
so much because in a sense we already
knew it
though the data of sense were necessary
to evoke and elicit this knowledge
or to put it less paradoxically our
systems of belief are those that the
Mind as a biological structure is
designed to construct
we interpret experience as we do because
of our special mental design
we attain knowledge when the inward
ideas of the Mind itself
and the structures it creates conform to
the nature of things
certain elements of the rationalist
theories must be discarded
but the general outlines seem plausible
enough
work of these past years has shown that
much of the detailed structure of the
visual systems is wired in
though triggering experience is required
to set the system in operation
there is evidence that the same may be
true of the auditory structures that
analyze at least some phonetic
distinctive features
as techniques of Investigation have
improved Bauer argues so has the
apparent sophistication of the infant
perceptual system
he reviews evidence suggesting that the
infant perceptual system seems capable
of handling all of the traditional
problems of the perception of
three-dimensional spaces perception of
solidity distance size distance and
variance and size constancy
thus contrary to the Berkeley and
tradition the world of the infant would
seem to be inherently tridimensional
there is evidence that before infants
are capable of grasping they can
distinguish graspable from ungraspable
objects
using purely visual information
Gregory observes that the speed with
which babies come to associate the
properties of objects and go on to learn
how to predict hidden properties and
future events would be impossible unless
some of the structures of the world were
inherited somehow innately built into
the nervous system
He suggests further that there may be a
grammar of vision rather like the
grammar of human language and possibly
related to the latter in the evolution
of the species employing this grammar of
vision largely innate higher animals are
able to read from retinal images even
hidden features of objects and predict
their immediate future States thus to
classify objects according to an
internal grammar to read reality from
their eyes
the neural basis for this system is
gradually coming to be understood
since the pioneering work of Hubbell and
Wiesel 1962
more generally there is every reason to
suppose that learning Behavior occurs
via modification of an already
functional structural organization
survival would be improbable if learning
in nature required the lengthy
repetition characteristic of most
conditioning procedures
and it is well known that animals
acquire complex systems of behavior in
other ways
despite the plausibility of many of the
leading ideas of the rationalist
tradition
and its Affinity in crucial respects
with the point of view of the Natural
Sciences
it has often been dismissed or
disregarded in the study of behavior and
cognition
it is a curious fact about the
intellectual history of the past few
centuries that physical and mental
development have been approached in
quite different ways
no one would take seriously a proposal
that the human organism learns through
experience to have arms rather than
wings
or that the basic structure of
particular organs results from
accidental experience
rather it is taken for granted that the
physical structure of the organism is
genetically determined though of course
variation along such Dimensions as size
rate of development and so forth will
depend in part on external factors from
embryo to mature organism a certain
pattern of development is predetermined
with certain stages such as the onset of
puberty or the termination of growth
delayed by many years
variety Within These fixed patterns may
be of great importance for human life
but the basic questions of scientific
interest have to do with the fundamental
genetically determined scheme of growth
and development that is characteristic
of the species
and that gives rise to structures of
marvelous intricacy
the species characteristics themselves
have evolved over long stretches of time
and evidently the environment provides
conditions for differential reproduction
hence evolution of the species
but this is an entirely different
question
and here too questions can be raised
about the physical laws that govern this
evolution
surely too little is known to justify
any far-reaching claims
the development of Personality Behavior
patterns and cognitive structures in
higher organisms has often been
approached in a very different way
it is generally assumed that in these
domains social environment is the
dominant Factor
the structures of mind that develop over
time are taken to be arbitrary and
accidental
there is no human nature apart from what
develops as a specific historical
product
according to this view typical of
empiricist speculation certain general
principles of learning that are common
in their Essentials to all or some large
class of organisms
suffice to account for the cognitive
structures attained by humans structures
which incorporate the principles by
which human behavior is planned
organized and controlled
I dismiss without further comment the
Exotic though influential view that
internal States should not be considered
in the study of behavior
but human cognitive systems when
seriously investigated prove to be no
less marvelous and intricate than the
physical structures that develop in the
life of the organism
why then should we not study the
acquisition of a cognitive structure
such as language more or less as we
study some complex bodily organ
at first glance
proposal may seem absurd
if only because of the great variety of
human languages
but a closer consideration dispels these
doubts
even knowing very little of substance
about linguistic universals
we can be quite sure that the possible
variety of languages is sharply limited
gross observations suffice to establish
some qualitative conclusions thus it is
clear that the language each person
acquires is a rich and complex
construction hopelessly underdetermined
by the fragmentary evidence available
this is why scientific inquiry into the
nature of language is so difficult and
so limited in its results
the conscious mind is endowed with no
Advanced knowledge or recalling
Aristotle with only insufficiently
developed Advanced knowledge
thus it is frustrated by the limitations
of available evidence and faced by far
too many possible explanatory theories
mutually inconsistent but adequate to
the data or as unhappy estate it can
devise no reasonable Theory
nevertheless individuals in a speech
Community have developed essentially the
same language
this fact can be explained only on the
assumption that these individuals employ
highly restrictive principles that guide
the construction of grammar
furthermore humans are obviously not
designed to learn one human language
rather than another
the system of principles must be a
species property powerful constraints
must be operative restricting the
variety of languages
it is natural that in our daily life we
should concern ourselves only with
differences among people
ignoring uniformities of structure
different intellectual demands arise
when we seek to understand what kind of
organism a human really is
the idea of regarding the growth of
language as analogous to the development
of a bodily organ is thus quite natural
and plausible
it is fair to ask why the empiricist
belief to the contrary has had such
appeal to the modern temper
why has it been so casually assumed that
there exists a learning theory that can
account for the acquisition of cognitive
structures through experience
is there some body of evidence
established through scientific inquiry
or observation or introspection that
leads us to regard mental and physical
development in such different ways
surely the answer is that there is not
science offers no reason to accept the
common Maxim that there is nothing in
the intellect which was not first in the
senses
or to question the denial of this Maxim
in rationalist philosophy
investigation of human intellectual
achievements even of the most
commonplace sort gives no support for
this thesis
empiricist speculation and the science
of behavior that has developed within
its terms have proved rather barren
perhaps because of the peculiar
assumptions that have guided and limited
such inquiry the grip of empiricist
Doctrine in the modern period outside of
the Natural Sciences is to be explained
on sociological or historical grounds
the position itself has little to
recommend it on the ground of empirical
evidence or inherent plausibility or
explanatory power
I do not think that this Doctrine would
attract the scientist who is able to
discard traditional myth and to approach
the problems afresh
rather it serves as an impediment an
insurmountable barrier to fruitful
inquiry much as the religious dogmas of
an earlier period stood in the way of
the Natural Sciences
it is sometimes argued that modern
empiricism overcomes the limitations of
the earlier tradition
but I think that this belief is
seriously an error
Hume for example
presented a substantive theory of the
secret Springs and principles by which
the human mind is actuated in its
operations
in his investigation of the foundations
of knowledge he suggested specific
principles that constitute a species of
Natural Instincts
modern empiricists who disparage Hume
have simply replaced his theory by
vacuous systems that preserve empiricist
or more narrowly behaviorist terminology
while depriving traditional ideas of
their substance
I have discussed this matter elsewhere
cited from chapter 4 and will not pursue
it here
in recent years many of these issues
long dormant have been revived in part
in connection with the study of language
there has been much discussion of the
so-called innateness hypothesis which
holds that one of the faculties of the
Mind common to the species is a faculty
of language that serves the two basic
functions of rationalist theory
it provides a sensory system for the
preliminary analysis of linguistic data
and the schematism that determines quite
narrowly a certain class of grammars
each grammar is a theory of a particular
language specifying formal and semantic
properties of an infinite array of
sentences
these sentences each with its particular
structure constitute the language
generated by the grammar
the language is so generated are those
that can be learned in the normal way
the language faculty give an appropriate
stimulation will construct the grammar
the person knows the language generated
by the constructed grammar this
knowledge can then be used to understand
what is heard and to produce discourse
as an expression of thought within the
constraints of the internalized
principles
in a manner appropriate to situations as
these are conceived by other mental
faculties
free of stimulus control
questions related to the language
faculty and its exercise are the ones
that for me at least
give a more General intellectual
interest to the technical study of
language
I would now like to consider the
so-called innateness hypothesis to
identify some elements in it that are or
should be controversial
and to sketch some of the problems that
arise as we try to resolve the
controversy
then we may try to see what can be said
about the nature and exercise of the
linguistic competence that has been
acquired
along with some related matters
a preliminary observation is that the
term innateness hypothesis is generally
used by critics rather than Advocates of
the position to which it refers
I have never used the term because it
can only mislead every theory of
learning that is even worth considering
incorporates an innateness hypothesis
thus hume's theory proposes specific
innate structures of mind
and seeks to account for all of human
knowledge on the basis of these
structures
even postulating unconscious and innate
knowledge
cited from chapter 4.
the question is not whether learning
presupposes innate structure of course
it does that has never been in doubt
but rather what these innate structures
are in particular domains
what is a theory of learning is there
such a theory as the theory of learning
waiting to be discovered
let us try to sharpen and perhaps take
some steps towards answering these
questions
consider first how a neutral scientist
that imaginary ideal might proceed to
investigate the question
the natural First Step would be to
select an organism oh
and a reasonably well-delimited
cognitive domain D and to attempt to
construct the theory that we might call
the learning theory for the organism o
in the domain d
this Theory
call it LT for o in D
can be regarded as a system of
principles a mechanism a function which
has a certain input and a certain output
its domain and range respectively
the input to the system LT for o in D
will be an analysis of data in D by o
the output which is of course internally
represented not overt and exhibited will
be a cognitive structure of some sort
this cognitive structure is one element
of the cognitive state attained by o
for example
take o to be humans and D language
then LT for H in L the learning theory
for humans in the domain language
will be the system of principles by
which humans arrive at knowledge of
language given linguistic experience
that is given a preliminary analysis
that they develop for the data of
language
or take o to be rats and D to be maze
running
then LT for R in m is the system of
principles used by rats in learning how
to run mazes
the input to LT for R in m is whatever
preliminary analysis of data is used by
rats to accomplish this feat
and the output is the relevant cognitive
structure
however it should properly be
characterized as a component of the
state achieved by the rat who knows how
to run a maze
there is no reason to doubt that the
cognitive structure attained and the
cognitive state of which it is a
constituent will be rather complex
to facilitate the discussion let us make
two simplifying assumptions
assume first that individuals of the
species o under investigation are
essentially identical with respect to
their ability to learn over the domain d
for example that humans do not defer in
language learning capacity
second assume that learning can be
conceptualized as an instantaneous
process in the following sense
assume that LT for o in D is presented
with a cumulative record of all the data
available to O up to a particular moment
and that LT for o in D operating on that
data produces the cognitive structures
attained at that moment
neither of these assumptions is true
there are individual differences and
learning takes place over time sometimes
extended time
I will return later to the question of
just how false these assumptions are
I think that they give a useful first
approximation
helpful for the formulation of certain
issues and possibly much more
to pursue the study of a given LT for o
and D in a rational way
we will proceed through the following
stages of inquiry
one set the cognitive domain d
2. determine how o characterizes data in
D
pre-theoretically thus constructing what
we may call the experience of O and D
recall the idealization to instantaneous
learning
three
determine the nature of the cognitive
structure attained that is determined as
well as possible what is learned by o in
the domain d
four
determine LT for o in D the system that
relates experience to what is learned
step 4 relies on the results attained in
steps 2 and 3.
to avoid misunderstanding perhaps I
should stress that the ordering of steps
is a kind of rational reconstruction of
rational inquiry in practice there is no
strict sequence
work at level 4 for example May convince
us that our original delimitation of D
was faulty that we have failed to
abstract a coherent cognitive domain
or it may lead us to conclude that we
have misconstrued the character of what
is learned at step 3.
it remains true nevertheless that we can
hope to gain some insight at the level
of step four
only to the extent that we have achieved
some understanding at levels 2 and 3.
and have selected wisely or luckily at
level one
it is senseless to try to relate two
systems in this case experience and what
is learned without some fairly good idea
of what they are
parenthetically we might observe that
step three is missing in many
formulations of psychological theory
much to their detriment in fact even the
concept what is learned is missing and
familiar at learning theories where it
is missing the basic questions of
learning theory cannot even be
formulated
how does the study of behavior fit into
this framework
surely a prerequisite to the study of
behavior is a grasp of the nature of the
organism that is behaving in the sense
of prerequisite just explained
an organism has attained a certain State
through maturation and experience
it is faced with certain objective
conditions
it then does something in principle we
might want to inquire into the mechanism
M that determines what the organism does
perhaps probabilistically
given its past experience and its
present stimulus conditions I say in
principle because I doubt that there is
very much that we will be able to say
about this question
no doubt what the organism does depends
in part on its experience
but it seems to me entirely hopeless to
investigate directly the relation
between experience and action rather if
we are interested in the problem of
causation of behavior as a problem of
science
we should at least analyze the relation
of experienced Behavior into two parts
first LT which relates experience to
cognitive State and second a mechanism
MCs
which relates stimulus conditions to
behavior given the cognitive State c s
in place of the Hopeless task of
investigating m
as in relating experience and stimulus
conditions to behavior we may more
reasonably undertake Research into the
nature of LT and MCs
1. M experience stimulus and conditions
cause Behavior
2. LT experience causes cognitive State
CS
3.
MCS stimulus conditions cause Behavior
given CS
I think that we can make considerable
progress towards understanding LT as in
relating experience to cognitive state
that is towards understanding particular
learning theories for organisms in
domains
for various choices of D given o and the
interaction among them it is this
problem that I want to consider here
I doubt that we can learn very much as
scientists at least
about the second of these two parts MCs
but it seems to me most unlikely that
there will be any scientific progress at
all if we do not at least analyze the
problem of causation of behavior into
the two components LT and MCS and their
elements
an attempt along the lines of
investigating M the study directly the
relation of behavior to past and current
experience
is doomed to triviality and scientific
insignificance
returning to the problem of learning
suppose that we have determined a number
of learning theories of organisms in
domains
for various choices of organism o and
cognitive domain d
we can now turn to the question what is
learning theory
or better
is there such a theory as learning
theory
the question might be put in various
ways
for example the following two
one
is it the case that however we select
organism and domain we find the same
learning theory for organism and domain
2.
are there significant features common to
all learning theories for organisms in
domains
before considering these questions
Let Us return to the first of our
simplifying assumptions
namely with regard to variability within
the species o
I would like to suggest that the
interesting questions of learning theory
those that might lead to a theory that
is Illuminating and that will ultimately
relate to the body of Natural Science
more generally
will be those for which our first
assumption is essentially correct that
is the interesting questions those that
offer some hope of leading to insight
into the nature of organisms will be
those that arise in the investigation of
learning in domains where there is a
non-trivial structure uniform for
members of o
with certain parameters relating to
rapidity of learning scope of learning
rate of forgetting and other such
marginal phenomena for which variability
is to be expected
these are the questions that deal with
significant characteristics of the
species
or perhaps of organisms generally
again I see no reason why cognitive
structures should not be investigated
rather in the way that physical organs
are studied
the natural scientist will be primarily
concerned with the basic genetically
determined structure of these organs and
their interaction
a structure common to the species in the
most interesting case abstracting away
from size variation and rate of
development and so on
if we can accept this judgment then LT
for o and D can be characterized for o
taken not as an individual but as a
species
hence for individuals apart from gross
abnormalities
and we may proceed to qualify question
one asking whether LT for o and D is
identical with LT for o Prime in D Prime
apart from such matters as rapidity
facility scope and retention which may
vary across species and to a lesser
extent among individuals of a given
species
consider now question one so qualified
surely the answer must still be affirm
no
even the crudest consideration suffice
to show that there is no hope of
reaching a positive answer to this
question
take o to be humans H and O Prime rats r
D to B language L and D Prime maze
running m
if even some vague approximation to
question 1 had a positive answer
we would expect humans to be as much
Superior to rats in May's learning
ability as they are in language learning
ability
but this is so grossly false that the
question cannot be seriously entertained
humans are roughly comparable to rats in
the domain M but incomparable in the
domain l
in fact it seems that white rats can
even best college students in this sort
of learning namely maze learning
the distinction between the pair LT for
H and LT for R in L on the one hand
and the pair LT for H in m l t for R in
m
on the other cannot be attributed to
sensory processing systems and the like
as we can see by transposing language
into some modality accessible to rats
see chapter 4.
as far as is now known
and I say this despite suggestions to
the contrary
the same is true if we consider other
organisms say chimpanzees in place of
rats putting this interesting but
peripheral question to the side it is
surely obvious at once that no version
of question 1 is worth pursuing
let us turn to the more plausible
speculation formulated in question 2.
no answer is possible for the present
the question is hopelessly premature
we lack an interesting conception of LT
for o and D
for various choices of O and D
there are I believe some substantive
steps possible towards LT for H in l
but nothing comparable in the other
domains of human learning
what is known about other animals to my
knowledge suggests no interesting answer
to two
animals learn to care for their young
build nests Orient themselves in space
find their place in a dominant structure
identify the species and so on but we
should not expect to find significant
properties which are common to the
various LTS for O's in D's that enter
into these achievements skepticism about
question two is very much an order on
the basis of the very little that is
known
I should think that for the biologist
the comparative physiologist or the
physiological psychologist such
skepticism would appear quite
unremarkable
thus for the present there seems to be
no reason to suppose that learning
theory exists
at least I see no interesting
formulation of the thesis that there is
such a theory that has initial
plausibility or significant empirical
support
within the odd variant of empiricism
known as behaviorism
the term learning theory has commonly
been used
not as the designation of a theory if it
exists that accounts for the attainment
of cognitive structures on the basis of
experience
like the investigation of LT which
relates experience to cognitive state
but rather as a theory that deals with
the relation of experienced Behavior
like the investigation of M
which relates experience and stimulus
conditions to behavior
since there is no reason to suppose that
learning theory exists there is
certainly no reason to expect that such
a theory of behavior exists
we might consider contentions more
plausible than those implicit in
questions one and two suppose that we
fix the organism o
and let D range over various cognitive
domains
then we might ask whether there is some
interesting set of domains
domain l through domain n such that
three
learning theory for organism in domain I
equals learning theory for organism in
domain J or learning theory for organism
in domain I is similar in interesting
ways to learning theory for organism in
domain J
there might be some way of delimiting
domains that would yield a positive
answer to 3. if so we could say that
within this delimitation the organism
learns in similar or identical ways
across cognitive domains it would be
interesting for example to discover
whether there is some cognitive domain D
other than language
for which LT for H and L is identical or
similar to LT for H and D to date no
persuasive suggestion has been made but
conceivably there is such a domain there
is no particular reason to expect that
there is such a domain and one can only
be surprised at the dogmatic view
commonly expressed that language
learning proceeds by application of
General learning capacities
the most that we can say is that the
possibility is not excluded
though there is no evidence for it and
little plausibility to the contention
even at the level of sensory processing
there appear to be adaptations directly
related to language
as already noted The Proposal that
language learning is simply an instance
of generalized learning capacities makes
about as much sense in the present state
of our knowledge as a claim that the
specific neural structures that provide
our organization of visual space must be
a special case of the class of systems
involved also in language use this is
true so far as we know only at a level
so General as to give no insight into
the character or functioning of the
various systems
for any organism oh we can try to
discover those cognitive domains D for
which the organism o has an interesting
LT for o in D that is an LT for o and D
that does not merely have the structure
of trial and error learning
generalization along physically given
Dimensions induction in any well-defined
sense of this notion and so on
we might Define the cognitive capacity
of O as the system of domains D for
which there is an interesting learning
theory LT for o and D in this sense
for D within the cognitive capacity of O
it is reasonable to suppose that a
schematism exists delimiting the class
of cognitive structures that can be
attained
hence it will be possible for such D for
a rich complex highly articulated
cognitive structure to be attained with
considerable uniformity among
individuals
apart from matters of rate scope
persistence
Etc
on the basis of scattered and restricted
evidence
investigating the cognitive capacity of
humans we might consider say the ability
to recognize and identify faces on
exposure to a few presentations to
determine the personality structure of
another person on brief contact thus to
be able to guess pretty well how that
person will react under a variety of
conditions
to recognize a Melody under
transposition and other modifications to
handle those branches of mathematics
that build on numerical or spatial
intuition to create art forms resting on
certain principles of structure and
organization and so on
humans appear to have characteristic and
remarkable abilities in these domains
in that they construct a complex and
intricate intellectual system rapidly
and uniformly on the basis of degenerate
evidence instructors created by
particularly talented individuals Within
These constraints are intelligible and
appealing exciting and thought-provoking
even to those not endowed with unusual
creative abilities
inquiry then might lead to non-trivial
learning theories for humans and domains
for it D so chosen such inquiry might
involve experimentation or even
historical investigation for example
investigation of developments in forms
of artistic composition or in
mathematics it seemed natural and proved
fruitful at particular historical
moments contributing to a mainstream of
intellectual Evolution rather than
diverting energy to an unproductive side
Channel
suppose that for a particular organism
oh we managed to learn something about
its cognitive capacity
developing a system of LTS for O's in
D's for various choices of D with the
rough properties sketched earlier
we would then have arrived at a theory
of the mind of o in one sense of this
term
we may think of the mind of O to adapt a
formulation of Anthony Kenny's as the
innate capacity of O to construct
cognitive structures that is
to learn
I depart here from Kenny's formulation
in two respects which perhaps deserve
mention
he defines mind as a second order
capacity to acquire intellectual
abilities such as knowledge of English
the latter itself a capacity or ability
an ability whose exercise is the
speaking understanding reading of
English moreover to have a mind is to
have the capacity to acquire the ability
to operate with symbols in such a way
that it is one's own activity that makes
them symbols and confers meaning on them
so that automata operating with formal
elements that are symbols for us but not
for them do not have Minds for the sake
of this discussion I have generalized
here Beyond first order capacities
involving operations with symbols and
I'm thus considering second order
capacities broader than mind in Kenny's
quite natural sense
so far there is no issue Beyond
terminology
secondly I want to consider mind in the
narrower or broader sense as an innate
capacity to form cognitive structures
not first order capacities to act
the cognitive structures attained enter
into our first order capacities to act
but should not be identified with them
thus it does not seem to be quite
accurate to take knowledge of English to
be a capacity or ability
though it enters into the capacity or
ability exercised in language use
in principle
one might have the cognitive structure
that we call knowledge of English fully
developed with no capacity to use this
structure and certain capacities to
carry out intellectual activities may
involve no cognitive structures but
merely a network of dispositions and
habits something quite different
knowledge understanding or belief is at
a level more abstract than capacity
there has been a tendency in modern
analytic philosophy to employ the notion
disposition or capacity
where the more abstract concept of
cognitive structure is I believe more
appropriate
see chapter 4.
I think we see here an unfortunate
residue of empiricism
the Notions capacity and family of
dispositions are more closely related to
behavior and language use they do not
lead us to inquire into the nature of
the ghost in the machine through the
study of cognitive structures and their
organization
as normal scientific practice and
intellectual curiosity would demand
the proper way to exercise the ghost in
the machine is to determine the
structure of the mind and its products
there is nothing essentially mysterious
about the concept of an abstract
cognitive structure created by an innate
faculty of Mind represented in some
still unknown way in the brain
and entering into the system of
capacities and dispositions to act and
interpret on the contrary
a formulation along these lines
embodying the conceptual competence
performance distinction
seems a prerequisite for a serious
investigation of behavior
Human Action can be understood only on
the assumption that first order
capacities and families of dispositions
to behave involve the use of cognitive
structures that Express systems of
unconscious knowledge belief expectation
evaluation judgment and the like
at least so it seems to me
returning to the main theme suppose that
we now select the problem in a domain D
that falls outside of O's cognitive
capacity
o will then be at a loss as to how to
proceed
o will have no cognitive structure
available for dealing with this problem
and no learning theory for organism in
domain available to enable it to develop
such a structure
oh will therefore have to proceed by
trial and error Association simple
induction and generalization along
certain available dimensions
some questions arise here which I put
aside
taking o to be humans
we will not expect the person to be able
to find or construct a rich and
insightful way to deal with the problem
to develop a relevant cognitive
structure in the intuitive unconscious
manner characteristic of language
learning and other domains in which
humans Excel
humans might be able to construct a
conscious scientific theory dealing with
problems in the domain in question
but that is a different matter
or better
a partially different matter
since even here there are crucial
constraints
an intellectually significant science an
intelligible explanatory Theory can be
developed by humans in case something
close to the true theory in a certain
domain happens to fall within human
science forming capacities
the LTS for H is in D's involved in
scientific inquiry whatever they may be
must be special and restrictive or it
would be impossible for scientists to
converge in their judgment on
particularly explanatory theories that
go far beyond the evidence at hand as
they customarily do in those few Fields
where there really is significant
progress
while at the same time rejecting much
evidence as irrelevant or beside the
point for the moment at least
the same LTS for H's in D's that provide
for the vast and impressive scope of
scientific understanding must also
sharply constrain the class of humanly
accessible Sciences
there is surely no evolutionary pressure
that leads humans to have Minds capable
of discovering significant explanatory
theories in specific fields of inquiry
thinking of humans as biological
organisms in the natural world
it is only a lucky accident if their
cognitive capacity happens to be well
matched to Scientific truth in some area
it should come as no surprise then that
there are so few sciences and that so
much of human inquiry fails to attain
any intellectual depth
investigation of human cognitive
capacity might give us some insight into
the class of humanly accessible Sciences
possibly a small subset of those
potential sciences that deal with
matters concerning which we hope vainly
to attain some insight and understanding
as a case in point
consider our near total failure to
discover a scientific theory that
provides an analysis of MCs
that is our very limited progress in
developing a scientific theory of any
depth to account for the normal use of
language
or other aspects of behavior
even the relevant Concepts seem lacking
certainly no intellectually satisfying
principles have been proposed that have
explanatory Force though the questions
are very old
it is not excluded that human signs
forming capacities simply do not extend
to this domain
or any domain involving the exercise of
will so that for humans these questions
will always be shrouded in mystery
note incidentally how misleading it
would be to speak simply of limitations
in human science forming capacity
limits no doubt exist but they derive
from the same source as our ability to
construct Rich cognitive systems on the
basis of limited evidence in the first
place
were it not for the factors that limit
scientific knowledge we could have no
such knowledge in any domain
suppose that in investigating organisms
we decide perversely to restrict
ourselves to tasks and problems that lie
outside their cognitive capacity
we might then expect to discover simple
laws of learning of some generality
suppose further that we Define a good
experiment as one that provides smooth
learning curves regular increments and
Extinction and so on
then there will be good experiments only
in domains that lie outside of O's
cognitive capacity
for example there will be no good
experiments in the study of human
language learning though there may be if
we concentrate attention on memorization
of nonsense syllables verbal Association
and other tasks for which humans have no
special abilities
suppose now that some branch of inquiry
develops Limited in principle 2 good
experiments in something like this sense
this discipline May indeed develop laws
of learning that do not vary too greatly
across cognitive domains for a
particular organism and that have some
cross-species validity
it will of necessity avoid those domains
in which an organism is specially
designed to acquire Rich cognitive
structures that enter into its life in
an intimate fashion
the discipline will be of virtually no
intellectual interest it seems to me
since it is restricting itself in
principle to those questions that are
guaranteed to tell us little about the
nature of organisms
for we can learn something significant
about this nature only by inquiry into
the organism's cognitive capacity
inquiry that will permit no good
experiments in the strange sense just
specified
though it may lead to the discovery of
intricate and no doubt highly specific
LTS for O's in D's
the results and achievements of this
perversely limited rather suicidal
discipline are largely an artifact
it will be condemned in principle to
investigation of peripheral matters such
as rate and scope of acquisition of
information
the relation between arrangement of
reinforcers and response strength
control of behavior and the like the
discipline in question may continue
indefinitely to amass information about
these matters
but one may question the point or
purpose of these efforts
a more elaborate study of cognitive
capacity raises still further questions
thus some intellectual achievements such
as language learning Falls strictly
within biologically determined cognitive
capacity
for these tasks we have special design
so that cognitive structures of great
complexity and interest develop fairly
rapidly and with little if any conscious
effort
there are other tasks no more complex
along any absolute scale assuming that
it is possible even to make sense of
this notion
which will be utterly baffling because
they fall Beyond cognitive capacity
consider problems that lie at the
borderline of cognitive capacity
these will provide opportunity for
intriguing intellectual play
chess for example is not so remote from
cognitive capacity as to be merely a
source of insoluble puzzles
but is at the same time sufficiently
beyond our natural abilities so that it
is challenging and intriguing
here we would expect to find that the
slight differences between individuals
are magnified to striking Divergence of
aptitude
the study of challenging intellectual
tasks might give some insight into human
intelligence at the borders of cognitive
capacity just as the study of the
ability to run a four-minute mile may
give useful information about human
physiology
but it would be pointless to study the
latter feat at a very early stage of our
understanding of human locomotion say if
we knew only that humans walk rather
than fly
correspondingly in the present state of
our understanding of mental abilities it
seems to me that for example the study
of Chess playing programs May teach
something about the theory of chess
but it is unlikely to contribute much to
the study of human intelligence
it is good procedure to study major
factors before turning to 10th order
effects to study the basic character of
an intricate system
before exploring its borders
though of course one can never know in
advance just what line of inquiry will
provide sudden illumination
in the case of human cognition it is the
study of the basic cognitive structures
within cognitive capacity the
development and use that should receive
priority I believe if we are to attain a
real understanding of the mind and its
workings
the preceding discussion is not very
precise
I hope that it is at least suggestive as
to how a rational study of learning
might proceed
let me now turn to the particular
question in the theory of learning that
concerns language
let us take o to be humans H and D to be
language l
what is LT for H in l
of the two simplifying assumptions
mentioned earlier the first invariably
across the species is so far as we know
fair enough
it seems to provide a close
approximation to the facts
let us therefore accept it with no
further discussion while keeping a
cautious and skeptical eye on the second
assumption that learning is
instantaneous
I will return to the latter in chapter
3.
LT for H in L is the system of
mechanisms and principles put to work in
acquisition of knowledge of language
acquisition of the specific cognitive
structure that we are calling grammar
given data which are a fair and adequate
sample of this language
the grammar is a system of rules and
principles that determine the formal and
semantic properties of sentences
the grammar is put to use interacting
with other mechanisms of mind
in speaking and understanding language
there are empirical assumptions and
conceptual distinctions embedded in this
account
and they might be wrong or misguided
but I think it is not unreasonable given
present understanding to proceed with
them
to relate these remarks to earlier
discussion note that I am insisting that
the relation of experience to action be
subdivided into two systems
LT for H and L
which relates experience to cognitive
State attained an MCS which relates
current conditions to action given
cognitive state attained
one of the cognitive structures entering
into the cognitive State Cs attained and
put to use by MCS is grammar
again I see few present prospects for
the scientific study of MCs
though the study of LT for hnl it seems
to me can be profitably pursued
let us Define universal grammar
ug
as the system of principles conditions
and rules that are elements or
properties of all human languages not
merely by accident but by necessity of
course I mean biological not logical
necessity
thus ug can be taken as expressing the
essence of human language
ug will be invariant among humans
ug will specify what language learning
must achieve if it takes place
successfully thus
ug will be a significant component of LT
for H and L
what is learned a cognitive structure
attained must have the properties of ug
though it will have other properties as
well accidental properties
each human language will conform to
Eugene languages will differ in other
accidental properties
if we were to construct a language
violating ug we would find that it could
not be learned by LT for H and L
that is it would not be learnable under
normal conditions of access and exposure
to data
possibly it could be learned by
application of other faculties of mind
LT for H and L does not exhaust the
capacities of the human mind
this invented language might be learned
as a puzzle or its grammar might be
discovered by scientific inquiry over
the course of generations with the
intervention of individual genius with
explicit articulation of principles and
careful experimentation
this would be possible if the language
happened to fall within the bounds of
the science forming component of human
cognitive capacity
but discovery of the grammar of this
language would not be comparable to
language learning just as inquiry in
physics is qualitatively different from
language learning
ug will specify properties of sound
meaning and structural organization
we may expect that in all of these
domains ug will impose conditions that
narrowly restrict the variety of
languages for familiar reasons we cannot
conclude from the highly restrictive
character of ug
that there is a translation procedure of
any generality or significance even in
principle
and quite obviously
nothing is implied about the possibility
of translating actual texts since a
speaker or writer naturally presupposes
a vast background of unspecified
assumptions beliefs attitudes and
conventions
the point is perhaps worth noting since
there has been much confusion about the
matter
for some discussion see Kaiser 1975.
we can gain some insight into ug hence
LT for H and L whenever we find
properties of language that can
reasonably be supposed not to have been
learned to make the discussion more
concrete consider a familiar example
perhaps the simplest one that is not
entirely trivial think of the process of
forming questions in English imagine
again our neutral scientist observing a
child learning English suppose that he
discovers that the child has learned to
form such questions
as those of figure a corresponding to
the associated declaratives
figure a the man is tall is the Man Tall
the book is on the table is the book on
the table Etc
observing these facts the scientist
might arrive at the following tentative
hypothesis as to what the child is doing
assuming now that sentences are analyzed
into words
hypothesis 1. the child processes the
declarative sentence from its first word
that is from left to right
continuing until he reaches the first
occurrence of the word is or others like
it may will Etc
he then proposes this occurrence of is
producing the corresponding question
with some concomitant modifications of
form that need not concern us
this hypothesis Works quite well it is
also extremely simple
the scientist has every right to be
satisfied and will be able to find a
great deal of evidence to support his
tentative hypothesis of course
the hypothesis is false
as we learned from such examples as
figure B and figure C
figure B
the man who is tall is in the room
is the man who is tall in the room
figure C
the man who is tall is in the room
is the man who tall is in the room
our scientist would discover surely that
on first presentation with an example
such as the man who is tall is in the
room
the child unneringly forms the question
B not C
if he can handle the example at all
children make many mistakes in language
learning but never mistakes such as
exemplified in C
if the scientist is reasonable
this discovery will surprise him greatly
for it shows that his simple hypothesis
1 is false
and that he must construct a far more
complex hypothesis to deal with the
facts the correct hypothesis is the
following ignoring complications that
are irrelevant here
hypothesis 2. the child analyzes the
declarative sentence into abstract
phrases
he then locates the first occurrence of
is
ETC that follows the first noun phrase
he then proposes this occurrence of is
forming the corresponding question
hypothesis 1. holds that the child is
employing a structure-independent rule
that is a rule that involves only
analysis into words and the property
earliest leftmost defined on word
sequences
hypothesis 2 holds that the child is
employing a structure-dependent rule a
rule that involves analysis into words
and phrases and the property earliest
defined on sequences of words analyzed
into abstract phrases
the phrases are abstract in the sense
that neither their boundaries nor their
categories noun phrase verb phrase Etc
need be physically marked sentences do
not appear with brackets intonation
boundaries regularly marking phrases
subscripts identifying the type of
phrase or anything of the sort
by any reasonable standards hypothesis 2
is far more complex and unlikely than
hypothesis 1. the scientists would have
to be driven by evidence such as figure
B or C to postulate hypothesis 2 in
place of the simpler and more Elementary
hypothesis 1.
correspondingly the scientist must ask
why it is that the child unneringly
makes use of the structure-dependent
rule postulated in hypothesis 2. rather
than the simpler structure independent
rule of hypothesis 1. there seems to be
no explanation in terms of communicative
efficiency or similar considerations
it is certainly absurd to argue that
children are trained to use the
structure dependent rule in this case
in fact the problem never arises in
language learning a person may go
through a considerable part of his life
without ever facing relevant evidence
but he will have no hesitation in using
the structure-dependent rule even if all
of his experience is consistent with
hypothesis 1. the only reasonable
conclusion is that ug contains the
principle that all such rules must be
structure dependent that is the child's
mind specifically its component LT for H
and L contains the instruction construct
a structure dependent rule ignoring all
structure independent rules the
principle of structure dependence is not
learned but forms part of the conditions
for language learning
to corroborate this conclusion about ug
hence LT for hnl
the scientist will ask whether other
rules of English are invariably
structure dependent
so far as We Know
the answer is positive
if a rule is found that is not structure
dependent a scientist will be faced with
a problem
he will have to inquire further into ug
to discover what additional principles
differentiate the two categories of
rules so that the child can know without
instruction that one is structure
dependent and the other not
having gotten this far
the scientist will conclude that other
languages must have the same property on
the assumption that humans are not
specifically designed to learn one
rather than another language say English
rather than Japanese
on this reasonable assumption the
principle of structure dependence
perhaps if necessary qualified as
indicated above must hold universally if
it holds for English
investigating the consequences of his
reasoning the scientist would discover
so far as We Know
that the conclusion is correct
more complex examples can be produced
but this simple one illustrates the
general point
proceeding in this way the scientist can
develop some rich and interesting
hypotheses about ug hence LT for H and L
us learning theory for humans in the
domain of language incorporates the
principle of structure dependence along
with other more intricate and I should
add more controversial principles like
it
I will return to some of these in the
third chapter
keeping this single example of a
principle of ug in mind let us return
now to the innateness hypothesis
recall that there is no issue as to the
necessity for such a hypothesis only as
to its character
assuming still the legitimacy of the
simplifying assumption about
instantaneous learning the innateness
hypothesis
will consist of several elements
principles for the preliminary
pre-theoretic analysis of data as
experience which serves as input to LT
for H in l
properties of ug which determine the
character of what is learned other
principles of A Sort not discussed in
the foregoing sketch we might quite
reasonably formulate the theory of
language so as to reflect this way of
looking at LT for H and L
a theory is a system of principles
expressed in terms of certain Concepts
the principles are alleged to be true of
the subject matter of the theory a
particular presentation of a theory
takes some of the concepts as primitive
and some of the principles as axioms
the choice of Primitives and axioms must
meet the condition that all concepts are
defined in terms of The Primitives and
that all principles derive from the
axioms
we might choose to formulate linguistic
Theory by taking its primitive Concepts
to be those that enter into the
preliminary analysis of data as
experience
with the axioms including those
principles expressing relations between
the Primitive Concepts that enter into
this preliminary analysis thus the
Primitive Notions are epistemologically
primitive they meet an external
empirical condition apart from
sufficiency for definition
the defined terms belong to UG and the
principles of ug will be theorems of
this Theory
linguistic Theory so construed is a
theory of ug incorporated into LT for
hnl in the manner described
the innateness hypothesis then can be
formulated as follows linguistic Theory
the theory of ug construed in the manner
just outlined is an innate property of
the human mind in principle we should be
able to account for it in terms of human
biology
to the extent that our simplifying
assumption about instantaneous learning
must be revised along lines to which I
will return we must accordingly
complicate the innateness hypothesis
a fuller version of the innateness
hypothesis for humans will specify the
various domains belonging to cognitive
capacity The Faculty of Mind LT for H
and D for each such domain d
the relations between these faculties
their modes of maturation and the
interactions among them through time
alongside of the language faculty and
interacting with it in the most intimate
way is the faculty of mind that
constructs what we might call Common
Sense understanding a system of beliefs
expectations and knowledge concerning
the nature and behavior of objects their
place in a system of natural kinds the
organization of these categories
and the properties that determine the
categorization of objects and the
analysis of events
a general innateness hypothesis will
also include principles that bear on the
place and role of people in a social
world the nature and conditions of work
the structure of human action will and
choice and so on
these systems may be unconscious for the
most part and even beyond the reach of
conscious introspection
one might also want to isolate for
special study the faculties involved in
problem solving construction of
scientific knowledge artistic creation
and expression play or whatever proved
to be the appropriate categories for the
study of cognitive capacity and
derivatively Human Action
in the next two chapters
I want to say something more about a few
of these mental faculties and their
interaction